we all have our morning routines
and lately mine starts here
with an obsessive check on the status of
my absentee palette
looks like the county board of elections
received my ballot
on october 27th but it says they still
need to
process my voter id envelope
and verify the signature
even before the coronavirus struck
more americans each election were either
voting early
or voting by mail but in 2020
these numbers are expected to skyrocket
the way americans choose their president
is complicated
even in a relatively normal election
year
in 2020 voters are facing a pandemic
an underfunded postal service
and the closure of polling locations in
battleground states
like georgia ohio arizona and texas
it's enough to make you just want to
tune out until it's over
but once you know how votes are counted
you can understand
why yours counts
in most states there are four ways
americans can vote
in person before election day on
election day
mailing an absentee ballot or placing it
in a secure drop box
each of the more than 3 000 counties in
the u.s
has its own rules but voting in person
generally
looks something like this when they show
up to vote
election officials check each voter's
name and address
to make sure that they're registered and
voting in the right place
these employees always work in teams of
two and both workers can't be
from the same political party voters
cast their ballots in private
either by filling out a paper ballot or
using an electronic voting machine
election officials collect the completed
paper ballot they check the voter's name
off a list and then place the ballot in
a secure box
at polling sites with electronic voting
machines a computer records two separate
pieces of information
the voter's name and the date they voted
and their vote choices
separating names and vote choices
ensures that voters preferences stay
secret
the machine also prints out a receipt
with just that first piece of
information
election officials check the voter's
name off a list and place the receipt in
a secure box
step one of the process looks pretty
much the same whether you're voting
early
or on election day for those voting
absentee it looks a little different
in some states every single registered
voter gets an absentee ballot in the
mail
but in most states voters have to fill
out a request form like this one
to get a ballot mailed to them once they
fill out their ballot
voters can either mail it to the county
board of elections
drop it off in person or place it in an
official ballot drop box
before they can be counted absentee
ballots have to go through an
extra step verification election
officials
always working in those bipartisan teams
scan the sealed envelopes into a
computer system
next they check the signature on the
ballot envelope
against the signature in the state's
voter registration database
in missouri voters also need to get
their ballot envelope stamped and signed
by a notary public
other states require a witness signature
if an envelope is missing one of those
requirements
the whole ballot is invalid most states
start this whole verifying process
weeks before election day but wisconsin
and pennsylvania
two crucial battleground states don't
start verifying mail-in ballots
until election day another one michigan
doesn't start until the day before once
the envelopes are verified
election officials unseal them and store
the ballots in a secure box until
it's time to start counting all paper
ballots
both from absentee and in-person voting
are tabulated using a machine
the data is stored on a memory card and
the counted ballots go back
in their secure box election officials
combine the counts from the paper
ballots and the electronic voting
machines
and the individual polling places report
these numbers to the county board of
elections
which reports them to the state board of
elections
at both the county and the state level
members of one political party
can't have a majority on these boards on
election day
polling places and county boards are
continually counting and reporting new
numbers every hour or so
state boards of elections typically post
the counts online
after the polls close and keep updating
them as more numbers
come in it takes a while for all these
votes to be counted
sometimes hours sometimes days when you
hear
this on tv on election night and look at
all these wins we're projecting for
hillary clinton
that doesn't mean all the votes in that
state have been counted
news networks make projections based on
a certain percentage of votes
and they don't always get it right a big
call to make cnn announces that we call
florida in the al gore column standby
standby
cnn right now is moving
our earlier declaration of florida back
to the
too close to call column news networks
make a lot of money
marketing election night like it's the
super bowl but there's something to be
said for adjusting our expectations a
little
especially during a pandemic after all
the law in most states gives state
boards of elections
weeks to make sure that their vote
counts are complete and accurate
before certifying them as official i'm
gonna keep checking up on my ballot
every morning
and reminding my friends to do the same
but
on election night i'd rather leave the
projections to the pundits and rest up
democracy is a marathon not a sprint
you